what's up everybody it's Warren welcome
back to the cosmic wonder and yes I know
that the Spider-Man no way home trailer
has leaked online and no I have not seen
it I do appreciate everybody sending it
to me and the first time I saw it it
took me about 10 seconds to realize what
I was watching and then it was such a
bad quality of video I was like no I'm
just gonna wait till the actual trailer
comes out because we're in the end game
now this is just a quick video to catch
you up to speed on everything that's
happened from last night to this morning
because a lot has really happened for
starters as most of you I'm sure have
heard and I just mentioned it the
trailer got leaked I'm not going to post
it I actually couldn't if I tried
because Sony is doing everything they
can to copyright and take down anybody
who's posting this video and for those
of you who watched it and want to watch
it trust me I totally get it but it's
just such bad quality from the 10
seconds that I saw I'd much rather wait
till the real thing comes out now the
trailer was leaked and after a few hours
of it being leaked we finally heard
something from Tom Holland himself he
posted on his Instagram story and it
simply said you ain't ready now
obviously this is referring to the
trailer if it was referring to anything
else I would be absolutely flabbergasted
because remember tonight is cinemacon
where they are going to be showing
footage and probably the actual trailer
for Spider-Man no way home and
originally this is what we were relying
on we were relying on the trailer being
shown at cinemacon and shortly after it
being released to the public now whether
or not the reports that stated it was
supposed to come this morning were
accurate or not is kind of irrelevant at
this point because literally everything
could have changed due to the fact that
the trailer was leaked and for those of
you stating that at this point Sony just
needs to release the trailer trust me I
understand and I agree with you the
trailer is out there they should release
the actual thing now but here's
everything that I've heard so far about
the trailer up until this point so I
think most of you know I've stated this
plenty of times I have two personal
sources when it comes to trailers
they've really never been wrong doesn't
mean they can't be but they haven't so
far one of them has not gotten back to
me in regards of the trailer the other
has told me a little bit of information
and the information is that it will be
shown to the Press at Cinema con tonight
the trailer will then drop late tonight
or tomorrow this is what he has heard
and then I followed up with is this 100
confirmed in which he replied no
anything could change and I want to
stress that because I don't want people
to get their hopes up and then get let
down that's not what I want to do I do
my best to keep everybody informed but I
don't want to let people down but this
is what I've heard and some other
accounts on Twitter that have been known
to provide accurate leaks and
information have also been stating the
same things tonight or tomorrow big
screen leaks was one of them and
apparently they were talking about the
things in the trailer before the trailer
got leaked in which it did confirm so
I've heard I have not watched the
trailer yet to me it would just be so
weird if Sony did not release the
trailer within the next 24 hours it was
leaked online and they're going to be
showing it to the Press at cinemacon and
the details of the trailer are going to
get out even more than they have been I
really can't imagine Sony not releasing
the trailer it just really doesn't make
any sense but nothing really has made
sense so far in terms of no way home so
we'll have to wait and see I do
personally believe that it is going to
be out within the next 24 hours however
that is not confirmed I will be posting
updates on Twitter and Instagram so if
you want to stay up to date in real time
follow me on there and one last thing
there have been some photos going around
that apparently show Tom Holland
Spider-Man and Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
together in a BTS shot this has
seemingly been proved to be fake if you
zoom in enough on Toby Maguire you can
tell that he's kind of transparent and
you can see through him which means that
he's photoshopped sorry to disappoint
but from what people have told me about
the trailer and what I've seen online
this trailer is going to confirm the
spider-verse so not much longer to wait
at this point hopefully the next video I
do is a Spider-Man no way home official
trailer reaction followed up with a
breakdown video of course if not if I
hear anything about the trailer I'll be
sure to update you tomorrow thank you
all for the continued support if if you
want to stay up to date on Spider-Man no
way home and other Marvel news consider
subscribing to the channel and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof